we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david t take a
listen to this voicemail hi david i was
wondering if you ever just look at
current events or see how things are
being played out and just forever isn't
just lose faith and that people can do
the right things for example stuff like
climate change or healthcare in our
country
yes i mean the answer is yes i myself
losing faith all the time no don't give
up david you got to keep the faith yeah
people right in sometimes and they say
you know you got to keep going but it's
i think any person who's even remotely
invested in the future of humanity would
be a little bit disaffected right now
don't you think yeah it's one of those
things though if you know you're screwed
do you just put on a good face for it or
do you just fess up to the reality of
the situation yeah no I know what you're
saying it's at a certain point it's
hello I think I told the story on the
bonus show after our vacation very often
during vacations I'll sort of disconnect
from what's going on politically and the
truth is that because our planet is
pretty big most individual things that
happen are not going to affect you as an
individual and when we're paying
attention to the news the way we do for
the production of the show it often
feels like so much more of what's going
on directly impacts our day to day but
the truth is most of what goes on in our
planet does not impact our day to day
future of climate change is obviously an
exception to that I'm not talking about
that and when I was on vacation and out
of the country a couple of weeks ago and
deliberately not paying attention to
what was going on there is a certain you
know I understand the concept of
ignorance is bliss yes I completely
understand it and it often is easier on
a day-to-day basis just not to even get
wrapped up listen if something happens
in my immediate location I'm going to
know it and I'm going to deal with it
but there is something comforting about
tuning it out every once in a while
sometimes it's nice to look at humanity
from the outside and kind of disconnect
yourself yeah and the other point I
would make is that I keep the faith when
it comes to what the Republicans are
doing and what's on
Trump is doing because a lot of those
things can be undone in the future
unfortunately climate change is one of
those things that we can't really
reverse yes it is and there's probably
other other issues on that list or at
least that while they can be reversed it
takes a long time a Supreme Court
selection as an example a lifetime
appointment on today's bonus show we are
going to talk about student loans that
were designed to fail we are going to
talk about firefighting drones and other
new drone applications and I will tell
you the story of my flight back back
from the conference in Las Vegas last
week not a surprise to people who have
been watching or listening to the show
for a while it was not the smoothest
trip back from Las Vegas which often is
the case for me when it comes to air
travel so all of those stories and more
on the bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up
I voted 17 as the coupon code and
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
make a pledge that's it make a pledge I
don't know what else to say we'll talk
to you on the bonus show